as much as we'd like to none of us can
reliably trust any one source for all
our information because of this we
quickly learn to spot the fake and save
the truth for future reference this is
our memory we begin with a nearly blank
page and continually add to it as we
learn and grow but we never run out of
paper
our brains can hold an estimated 2 point
5 petabytes of information remember that
number by the way by doing this work
ourselves we minimize the influence
others have on our information our
understanding is not made of their truth
but the truth or so we think
but we are far too confident in our
memories and ironically our poor memory
is exactly why we overestimate it when
you come across a suspicious website or
a biased newspaper you can easily check
its validity any claim can be
corroborated or disproven simply by
comparing it to other sources now for a
moment distance yourself from your own
memory and see it not as a perfect
harddrive that you record - but as
simply another newspaper or website if
you wanted to check the validity of one
of your memories you'd simply be
comparing it to another memory that's
like using one page of a book to verify
another page in the same book because
there's no escaping memory you must rely
on it as a single perfect source of
truth and just as relying on any one
website or newspaper makes you
susceptible to propaganda and Distortion
your memory silently deceives you
another reason for your overconfidence
is that you don't remember what you
don't remember in other words there's a
survivorship bias we only see the
memories that survive those that we
remember when you forget to do something
you've by definition forgotten about it
you'll never realize that your memory
failed and every time you do remember
something it looks like proof of your
perfect memory of course it gets an A+
it isn't graded on the times it failed
in the 1980's a mother suspected that
her son was being abused at his daycare
when she called the police a large
investigation began hundreds of other
children were questioned and many were
also said to have been abused at the
daycare but what seemed like a clear
case soon turned bizarre when children
began remembering clowns underground
tunnels and even flying witches no
evidence was found
except that of a very interesting memory
phenomenon all these children weren't
lying they really did have vivid
memories they just weren't real at the
beginning the children had denied the
abuse but the story had generated a
panic rumors and fear were rampant which
led to incorrect assumptions
investigators wanted so badly to lock up
the bad guys that they created them the
children were told that they may have
suppressed memories of the abuse in this
process they were asked to imagine abuse
as it was described to them this
suggestive questioning technique was so
effective that 360 children soon went
from denying to providing colorful
details
now you might attribute this mistake to
the age of the children so let's look at
a study done on adults before this study
began parents of the study's
participants were asked to provide major
childhood events in the lives of the son
or daughter the study participants then
the researchers told the participants
that they were going to discuss the
memories provided by their parents among
these memories the researchers planted a
fake one do you remember when you went
to a wedding as a kid and accidentally
spilled a Punchbowl on the parents of
the bride at first participants couldn't
remember but when they returned days
later to complete the study many could
remember the fake event and some even
added their own details researchers have
created an environment in which they
could very easily implant false memories
both this study and the daycare
investigation show that we can not only
create completely false memories but
also that the circumstances which allow
for it are quite common all it takes is
an imagination and some details provided
by someone else and the event becomes
our own but it doesn't stop there
even recalling a memory is enough to
distort it when we remember something
we're really recalling the last time we
remembered it and each time we remember
something it gets changed ever so
slightly these changes would be
insignificant except that each time we
recall a memory it inherits all the
changes from your past recalls and gets
distorted even more our most important
memories a trip wedding or a moment with
a deceased relative are recalled most
often and are therefore most distorted
luckily we aren't completely defenseless
we all have what's called a meta memory
an understanding of our memory and its
limitations when you stop and think that
doesn't sound right
I think I'm misremembering you
metamemory has been triggered letting
you correct the mistake but memory
expert Julia Shaw writes in her book the
memory illusion meta memory is by no
means flawless however and in trying to
make sense of false memories we can
spend further narratives and come up
with excuses so as to make things fit in
other words this can backfire and in
trying to correct our memory we can end
up filling in gaps incorrectly planting
more false memories but of course you
aren't so gullible your memory must be
better than average so surely you can
recall the number I told you to remember
earlier don't feel bad if this video has
made you question your memory abilities
because the best way to improve it is to
be aware of its flaws hopefully now you
can understand the flaws of your brain
and do your best to adjust that is if
you can remember them this video was a
collaboration with a channel called poly
matter which absolutely deserves more
traffic than it currently gets if you'd
like to learn more about fascinating
topics like the one in this video make
sure to click over to poly matter and
check out their videos and give them
some love from second thought if you
enjoyed this video you can click here to
watch these next and if you're tired of
learning come watch me play video games
with a friend on my new gaming channel
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video